Callbacks, drag queens, and Star Trek. What else
could you expect from the Hocus Pocus sequel? Here
are some of the best blink-and-you'll-miss-it
moments, and beware: spoilers ahead!
The Salem of Hocus Pocus 2 is a town just as
obsessed with witchcraft and Halloween as it was
in the original film. However, this time, viewers
are also treated to the Salem Halloween festival,
featuring the 'famous' Sandy's Candy
Cauldron and an apple-bobbing booth
that doubles as a drowning pool. Salem,
in fact, is so obsessed with its heritage,
that it leans into its witch-burning
history a little too hard sometimes.
As Becca and Izzy head for the Magic Shop
after school, Mayor Traske stops them to
wish Becca a happy birthday. As they chat, a
woman dressed as a witch can be seen behind
them. The odd thing about the scene? She's
tied to a tree with a pyre built under her,
posing for photos while a man dressed as a Puritan
holds the camera. It's a small moment barely
visible in the background and easy to miss, but
subtly adds to the world-building all the same.
Hocus Pocus 2 weaves Salem's history in with the
modern day, creating a running gag throughout
the whole length of the film. Audiences might
have noticed the film's large number of Puritan
references, recalling the movie's opening shots
when Reverend Traske banishes young Winnifred.
In the present day, the high school mascot
is a Puritan, clearly visible through all
the scenes set in the school, as well as on
Mike and his fellow football players' jerseys.
Later, the Sanderson sisters
stumble on a look-alike contest,
decided by a group of judges dressed as Puritans.
"If these are all worshippers…"
"...then this must be the altar."
It's clearly an element of the
town's history that holds a lot of
meaning – even if you have to give the movie
a second watch to spot all the references.
The Hocus Pocus costume department has
always been part of the film's charm,
especially since building an entire
town full of Halloween fans requires
a lot of creativity. The original Hocus
Pocus film used authentic costumes from
other Disney movies. Naturally, the
Hocus Pocus 2 costume department also
gave audiences the chance to find several
cheeky call-backs to the original film.
"Mom?"
"Hm?"
"What are you supposed to be?"
"Madonna."
In Hocus Pocus 2, look for the return of Madonna
stomping away in the street during the musical
dance number. Fans might also have seen that
the Supremes are back. In the original film,
the trio of women wearing sparkly red
dresses can be seen in the front row,
right below the stage, becoming bewitched along
with the rest of the crowd. In Hocus Pocus 2,
all three are dancing through
town in the spellbound flash mob.
One of the classic scenes in the original
Hocus Pocus is when the Sanderson sisters
encounter the flirtatious devil, his
disappointed wife, and their demonic,
yappy little dog. Back in 1993, the devil was
played by the legendary Garry Marshall in an
uncredited cameo. His wife was played by his
real-life sister and actress, Penny Marshall.
Though both stars are sadly deceased, the
two lovable oddball characters are back in
Hocus Pocus 2 for those who watch closely. While
searching for Mayor Traske, Winnifred flies past
the window of a house where two men are watching
that scene on TV. Later, we see two people dressed
in costume as the devil and his wife standing
behind Mayor Traske in line for caramel apples.
Fans of RuPaul's Drag Race should have
noticed some familiar faces on screen
during Hocus Pocus 2, and honestly, who better
to face off against the three original witches?
The Sanderson sisters crash a Halloween
look-alike competition for themselves,
coming face to face with Ginger Minj, Kahmora
Hall, and Kornbread. As a notorious drama queen,
Winnifred is quick to banter
with the other Winnifred.
"Lose the teeth."
"Mind your business girl."
Director Anne Fletcher personally
invited Ginger Minj to join the
cast. In an interview with TooFab,
Ginger said that watching the three
witches flying around during
filming caused her to tear up.
"All three of them just take off flying over
our heads and that was the moment where I
just had tears streaming down my face...
9-year-old me is living their best life."
Only four of the original Hocus Pocus
actors returned for the second film:
Sarah Jessica Parker, Kathy Najimy, Bette
Midler, and the great Doug Jones. That's right,
Billy Butcherson, the gentle zombie
and ex-lover, is back for Hocus Pocus
2. In the film's opening scenes, Winnifred is
told she'll be marrying John Pritchett. It's
then that young Winnifred informs the whole
town that Billy Butcherson is her soulmate,
especially since they shared that
kiss in the graveyard. Scandalous.
And now, Billy Butcherson is resurrected once
again in service to the Sanderson sisters.
However, this time, Billy wants the world to know
that it was "only one kiss," not a fully committed
relationship — a running gag that lasts throughout
the film. But the real detail is in how the actor
managed to look exactly the same almost 30 years
later. Not only did the costume department create
an identical prosthetic for his face, but they
used the actual wig from the original film.
"The wig had been sitting on
display at someone's creature shop,
and they just took it off and put it back on me."
The original Hocus Pocus is filled
with comedic asides, most of which have
helped to make the enduring film a cult
classic. Hocus Pocus 2 is no different,
and in fact calls back some of the jokes
and lines from the first film. The most
prominent example comes about two-thirds
of the way through the film. On seeing his
not-so-beloved Winnifred again, Billy calls
her a withering hag. Fans of the first film
should recognize this insult as Thackery Binx
makes his last stand in front of the sisters.
"You hag. There are not enough children in
the world to make you young and beautiful."
"Hag."
"Uh oh."
So, they promptly turn him into a cat, as you do.
However, like many misunderstood women,
Winnifred is happy to reclaim the insult
when the sisters search the high
school for Max, Dani, and Allison.
The original Hocus Pocus makes it clear that
the Sanderson sisters are servants of Satan.
"Master!"
Allison even tells Max and Dani that their
beloved book was given to them by the devil
himself. However, Hocus Pocus 2 did a
bit of retconning with the introduction
of an evil female mentor dubbed Mother
Witch who gives them the book instead.
"Magic has a way of uniting
things that ought to be together."
But despite the switcheroo, die-hard audiences
of the original Hocus Pocus will know that the
mother isn't some random character thoughtlessly
added into the new film. The Sanderson sisters
mention their "mother" several times in the
1993 movie, once in a calming circle reminiscing
about "mother's scorpion pie" and later when they
salute their long-lost mother with their brooms.
Only the most eagle-eyed viewers would have
caught the name of the high school displayed
in the background behind Becca. In this scene
Becca and Izzy discuss their Halloween plans and
right behind them is "Samuel Skelton High
School," written right over the archway.
While it's tempting to connect the school's name
to the LVCRFT song "Skeleton Sam" that plays at
the beginning of the film, Samuel Skelton is
actually a real person from Salem's history.
Skelton was the first pastor of the First
Church in Salem, founded on August 6, 1629.
In modern-day Salem, the Sanderson sisters' spooky
old house has been turned into a delightful magic
shop. Naturally, this being a Disney film,
viewers should pay close attention to the
decorations shown in the background. For instance,
fans of Disney's classic Haunted Mansion ride
should recognize the skull of the "hatbox ghost"
standing out from a group of skulls in one corner.
That's not all though; sharp-eyed viewers
might have seen the words "Salem Apothecary"
written on the corner above the counter,
a clever Easter egg since the Sanderson
sisters talk about their father's apothecary
several times during the film. Finally,
in one scene, you can spot a basket of plush,
yarn-haired Sanderson sister dolls on a table.
No one would argue that Book had an important
role in the first Hocus Pocus. The spellbook,
which was apparently "bound in human skin," became
an iconic part of the Hocus Pocus
mythology and aesthetic. However,
it's in Hocus Pocus 2 that Book finally gets a
chance to shine, showing off its personality,
demonstrating its opinions, and even making
choices about who's going to be its next witch.
Fans may have noticed that when Book is hiding
from Becca, amongst the other non-sentient
spellbooks, it physically sweats. Because, get
it? It's bound in human skin. As a side note,
there's also a reference to Star Trek when
Book refuses to open onto the correct page
for the "Magici Maxima" spell. In a rage,
Winnifred shouts a famous Star Trek line:
"Resistance is futile!"
Did that line make it in because Doug Jones,
the actor and contortionist who plays Billy
Butcherson, stars as Saru in Star Trek:
Discovery? Or was it just a fun thing to
shout out at a book that suddenly
decided to have a mind of its own?
Movie-goers should know this one already —
stay until after the credits. Hocus Pocus 2
is no different from any other
superhero film, Muppet movie,
or animated film in modern history –
there's always something to see after
the credits roll. The original Hocus
Pocus shows Max and Dani's parents,
Jenny and Dave, emerging from the town hall a
little worse for wear after their night dancing.
In Hocus Pocus 2 fans are treated to the
possibility of yet another film. Cobweb,
Gilbert's black cat, jumps onto
a shelf in the back storeroom,
nosing among the boxes. Naturally, audiences
can see that one of the boxes is labeled "BF
#2 Candle." Could it be that audiences are
getting a third Hocus Pocus? Let's hope so!